so far we've learned what a complex
number is we've even learned how to
graph it and we learn how to add
subtract and multiply it and where I
left off in the last video is how do we
divide two complex numbers so I said
let's say I have one complex number Z 1
and that equals a plus B I I and I want
to divide that by Z 2 which is C plus D
I so let me ask you a question and I
touched on this in the last video and
let me I did it in a different in a
different color here we know that a plus
B times a minus B is equal to a squared
minus B squared and you can multiply it
out if in case you're not sure you
remember it's just a times a plus B
times a plus minus a times B minus plus
a times a and you'll get this I don't
know if I said that right but you know
how to do this anyway there's a review
if you need to do it so given that what
is what is C plus D what happens if we
do something very similar with a complex
number if we say C plus D I times C
minus D I well in this case a is C and B
is d I right so this is just going to be
equal to C squared minus D I squared D I
squared and that equals C squared minus
d squared I squared and that equals C
squared minus d squared and I squared is
negative 1 right so this is going to be
multiplied by negative 1 so it cancels
out this negative so you get C squared
plus d squared that's interesting when I
multiply a complex number times this
other number which is very similar to it
but it's kind of the the imaginary part
goes in the other direction when I
multiply the two I get a completely real
number
all of the eyes disappear and in general
this number if if we call this Zeit well
in our example this was z2 so if we say
that Z 2 equals C plus D I the quantity
C minus D I is called its conjugate and
that's just good terminology you know
and that the sign for conjugate is that
line over the top so the conjugate of z2
is C minus di or you could say the
conjugate of C minus di is equal to C
plus di or you could say the other way
around the conjugate of C plus di is
equal to C minus di and notice we're
just switching the direction in the
imaginary along the imaginary axis when
we take the conjugate of something what
that's it let me let me erase that and
go back to our original problem because
that's the conjugate is the tool we're
going to use to divide this so we know
what when we multiply an imaginary
number times its conjugate we get a real
number so and we know also if we
multiply we can multiply anything by 1
and we get the same number so let's
multiply the numerator and denominator
of this expression by the conjugate of
the denominator so let me do that so the
conjugate of the denominator it's going
to be C minus D I so C minus D I over C
minus D I right this is C plus D I so
this is its conjugate and so what do we
get so in the numerator we get AC I
don't want to run out of space I always
do a C so a times C - Adi - a D I these
eyes are keep looking funny this is an I
do plus BC i + b c i and then the last
term we have a plus B - B so it's
- BDI squared - B D I squared all of
that and when you know this is a plus B
times a minus B so it's equal to a
squared - B squared so this is going to
be equal to and this will become second
nature to you after a while but you
might want to just multiply it out this
equals C squared plus d squared and
don't take my word for it actually
algebraically multiply this out and just
realize you can only add real parts to
real parts and imaginary parts to
imagine parts so let me simplify that
that equals let's see the real parts
this is real AC and this is minus BD I
squared so the I squared is minus one so
it switches the sign here so it becomes
plus BD and we can get rid of di so the
real parts are AC plus BD that's that
and that and then the imaginary parts
are plus this one's positive slope with
that one first
BC minus ad I all of that over C squared
plus d squared and that still might not
look like a complex number to you but
then we can separate them out and we
could say well that equals AC plus BD
over C squared plus d squared and that's
the real part plus BC minus ad over C
squared plus d squared and that times I
and that's the imaginary part so you
can't
oh you can't merge when you're adding
and subtracting out the real part - the
imaginary part but you can most
definitely scale an imaginary number by
a real number and that's essentially
what we're doing we're multiplying 1
over C squared plus d squared times this
so the vision might seem a little
complicated when I write it all in
variables but let me give you an example
and you will hopefully see that it with
real numbers and whatnot real numbers
with actual numbers I should be careful
with what I say let's say I have
one one plus two I and I want to divide
that by I don't know let's divide it by
I'm going to pick a random number 2 plus
3i and so what do we do we multiply it
times the conjugate of the denominator 2
minus 3i over the over itself right
because then we're not changing the
number this is just 1 this simplifies to
1 it equals the bottom we can multiply
it out but hopefully a second nature to
you it equals 4 plus 9 right and because
that's just a squared plus B squared
right well I mean it's a squared minus B
squared but in the eyes when you
multiply and become a negative number
try it out if you don't if you don't
believe me and then the top we get 1
times 2 is 2 1 times minus 3i is minus
3i then you have 2 I times 2 which is
plus 4i and then you have 2 I times
minus 3i so that's minus 6 minus 6i
squared well what is I squared equal
that equals negative 1 so negative 1
times negative 6 get rid of the I
squared this becomes a positive so then
what are real parts are real parts are 2
& 6 so 2 plus 6 is 8 and what are our
imaginary parts minus 3i plus 4i so
that's just plus 1 I write minus 3 plus
4 is positive 1 so it's just plus 1 I
over 13 or we could write that is if we
wanted to write income to traditional
complex form is 8 over 13 plus 1 over 13
I so when I divide it by one complex
number by another I got another complex
number and an interesting exercise for
you to do is pick some random complex
numbers plot them out on on the complex
plane and see what happens when you
multiply them when you divide them when
you add them when you subtract them and
and and when you when you scale them or
when you take the conjugate and that
give you a better intuition of what's
going on with these numbers anyway I
will see you in the next video